pinball wizard more like pinball Jedi if  you're a fan of pinball fx2 zen pinball  2 or Star Wars pinball it's time to get  hype Zen studios and Lucasfilm are  bringing the force awakens tables to all  three of those games rey finn and poe  dameron will star in both of the new  tables which will also feature the first  order and bad guy kylo Ren they'll also  sports a new transforming environments  that means you'll get to visit 12  action-packed scenes from Star Wars  Episode 7 so spoiler alert I guess the  force awakens pack will cost you five  dollars for both tables on PC consoles  and handhelds you can also buy the  tables individually for three bucks on  Mac and two bucks on iOS and Android  Star Wars is in the first theme table to  be featured in Zen Pinball or it's  related games you can also get tables  for favorites like The Walking Dead and  plants vs zombies and whenever more  tables get announced you can check them  out at gamespot may the force be with  you